[Música]
qué sabemos de arizona ubicado en el
suroeste de eeuu el estado de arizona es
vecino del estado de california y
especialmente de méxico al sur
[Música]
apodado el estado del grand canyon es el
sexto más grande de eeuu con más de
siete millones de habitantes ofrece 11
votos del colegio electoral un estado
clave en la conquista de la casa blanca
la mayoría de la población tres quintas
partes se concentran en una sola región
la capital del estado phoenix arizona es
un estado rojo rojo como el cobre que
produce en cantidad y rojo como el
partido republicano que ha elegido
muchas veces entonces porque arizona es
un estado pendular tradicionalmente no
lo es desde 1952 el estado ha votado por
el candidato republicano excepto en 1996
cuando colocó a bill clinton en la
cabeza pero en 2020
arizona está al alcance de los
demócratas y la razón principal es
demográfica la población de arizona se
ha multiplicado por 7 desde la segunda
guerra mundial los recién llegados
principalmente emigrantes en su mayoría
mexicanos desde entonces muchos han
obtenido la ciudadanía estadounidense y
pesan un tercio de la población votantes
latinos que en su mayoría votan por
demócrata así que por lo tanto podrían
cambiar a arizona
[Música]